what's going on there citizens the
reject Nation this is part two of I
think we're going to do five part five
or six I'll figure it out we'll
see our we're doing a reaction to the
Spider-Man cut scenes of the game
Spider-Man 2 get it right well we're
doing this intro after already watching
a lot of it so I'm a little bit brain
dead but go watch part one if you
haven't seen part one this is part two
keep a look out for part three so flip
that like button subscribe click that
notification Bell let's roll the part
two
maybe these wind tunnels can give me a
boost that looks like so much fun using
the web Wings I'm so excited to do that
it's funny how the raft was such a
Monumental important level in the first
game MH and now we're just here so early
on
Scorpion oh suit is still damage from
Rhino beating the crap out of him or
oh yeah know it looked like it was
shattered on the visor
spot Mac
Guardian they really got to bring
scorpion back into the live action ready
for the next one or like actually just
bring him oh yeah we just saw we just
saw him what in homecoming right and
that was
it Mr
negative Martin Le
well if they're here you know some
really good situ oh Craven's going to
show up isn't he
yeah May he's going to let them loose
and go for a
hunt oh that's the guy who deleted his
father
mhm can I understand the rage
there Peter really thought this
through
miles you are emotionally compromised my
friend but I understand it's fine he's
going to have that rage to deal with and
Peter is going to once he gets
influenced by the dark that's going to
be interesting the dichotomy
yeah little early for fireworks we got
to
go whoa
red
yellow just accepted they're there like
NOP the Spider-Man are here make sure
the prisoners are
secure oh here we go take left protect
the ship B up on
me oh using cloaking
[Music]
Tech almost has like a prey feel to it
with their their
makeup gosh
dang even craving
goons are intimidating
looking I really should have
stretched stretching
important it's like like vulture
Tech die yeah I think you're
right oh what are you vulturous
kid wa
[Music]
somewhere Craven is twirling his
beard don't get distracted by the
spiders a worry lies
within
what
now it does seem like they got like B
attack
[Music]
yeah we got to get this ship get
free whoa damn dragging the ship
in what is the purpose of doing it this
way people inside are going to drown
I'll keep trying to get these things out
King Arthur makes this look so
easy
I got this there's more people inside
let me worry about
them my God damn this is horrifying you
got to get top side soon as I get
everyone
clear
oh my you're actually underwater
wow think I've ever seen webbing
underwater like this
m
whoa miles what are you exper now think
he got by scorpion did he get stun yeah
I mean we're seeing some of the
night have to get out of here cuz we saw
in the first game when Peter got stung
he had like a nightmarish effect some of
his Fe
ear yeah and it was all like dispersed
throughout the water yeah me out of here
oh
interesting
spidermane I thought this confrontation
would come
later what are you waiting for oh
boy come on you got to Rise Above This
miles I feel you man I'm not like
this what
the whoa is he being affected by the
negative
energy yeah he's never actually come
face to face with Lee huh clear we got
him oh was whatever that magnetic thing
was doing
leave you cannot
Escape chain lightning whoa that's a
Nifty skill what is this B of power I
can barely control
it Spider-Man they got
leak oh my God that's awesome miles do
you think you can handle Lee I can turn
around right now call them miles not
after what he did to my dad I have to
protect them they need me man right now
I'm a little more invested in Miles
nothing you got this I'll be back soon
you got this got that real interpersonal
conflict situation going on right now I
mean yeah the whole thing with Martin is
pretty damn personal but I'm Still
Loving the the wholey the Peter hairy
thing and then also the stuff with the
the payments and the house and all that
too I think the more compelling part is
currently
yeah get back
[Music]
here
wow these action sequences are so well
thought of it's only in one little spot
but it feels like a real Naval sequence
yeah
damn eron Taylor
Johnson
Spider-Man things just went from bad to
really bad fire
B that's well okay I'm on my way we'll
deal with scorpion
later oh no come
on this is
insane it won't start I got
you hang on to something man miles is
really coming to his own huh well I mean
yeah last game
whoa
wow face off eat your heart
[Music]
out I mean last game he really proved
himself but yeah he's uh he's even
better now wow
yeah
damn damn Le is getting messed up in
there no no no that propeller run I'll
stop it I'm here guys I love the
constant inclusion of having a safe
civilians yeah for sure it makes it more
feel
real God I'm so blinking what are the
Black Panther part two villains
again uh NE more yeah they're the his
people that's kind of what the vibe I'm
getting from them feel like right
now if only Titanic if they would have
had two Spider-Man
here we go here we go
oh oh
boy uhoh what are you going to do dude
no Focus
miles oh Peter's going to rip into him
wow so much of this is going to be about
not succumbing to giving to the darkness
I'm just going to let me
die you don't know what you took from
[Music]
me I love how he's one of them this is
talk Spider-Man let him go there's more
important things right
now oh my
goodness miles there's some real destru
destuction happening right
now wow Spiderman I need your
help dude come on
Miles you took the hero's oath let go
well that you said that's a common theme
in this game and you were right whoa oh
that is
amazing
wow seriously I I I wonder how like
Peter got done before
miles that's a great
question well I mean if there's one
thing this game has already done so far
is it's really elevated miles to the
point of like I don't know understand
how Peter did before miles
fortunately he got into situations that
didn't require miles people just die
people must have just been dying all the
time
it could have been way
worse dude Peter is just going to rip
into him now there's no sign of them I
don't think so any look up River nothing
but
debris or they're going to have a
chat who were those guys whoever they
are they're packing some serious Tech
and now they got all that plus Scorpion
and Lee hey whatever they're planning
we'll find them we'll stop them
yeah
Pete I'm sorry when I saw Lee inside
that ship I wanted to kill him my
Powers
they you think his energy got entangled
with your
[Music]
oh
oh but it
feels volatile that's why he was
thinking about negative stuff like that
makes sense actually
there
hey we'll put Lee back where he
belongs promise Peter's actually a
really good Mentor don't leave me
hanging trying to soak over here on
watch come
on you're too much
man man I've really taken it for granted
that we're getting a whole thing
with R2 Spider-Man yeah hang in there
miles Emily May Foundation what a cool
combo Harry's mom and an I was wondering
what this place
[Music]
was good on you
Harry he's going to get
[Music]
fired
oh that tree right that was at the um
Emily's tree yeah the tree that was in
uh Norman's apartment
perfect you made
it I thought you said this was a
startup yeah I was hoping for something
a little less this but my dad was the
one who you know he made all the
arrangements Peter
Parker
so what do you
think it's a far cry from that Chop Shop
that auto stop saying that name around
me and now that you're on
board this place is really going to
start
cooking damn particle
accelerator they're going to create the
flash dad deep hasn't decided he's
joining yet oh
really but I was going to give him a
tour let him decide for himself I want
to be a school
teacher all right I mean he
might you
know seeing you boys together
again right
then have
fun love how Norman's always wearing
green your badge out let's go
exploring not bad for a startup so the
first thing I want to show you is
downstairs Harry this place right Dad
went a little more over the top than I
would have the trees and stuff are
moving yeah that's uh taking 3D uh walls
to another level diverted my salary into
research projects installed a diverse us
on the right track and made sure all
research align with our mission I love
those missions in the first game sure
other people might not have but I love
those I had to look up how to be get
past them they were a little
hard I didn't have the patience for them
oh of
course that guy just go through the door
yeah little glitch there he's going
through the game is perfect Andrew don't
you question it perfect going through
tables
too you must be Peter so nice to meet
you I think you'll like this project
great to meet you Dr Young Harry says
you're working with bees yes and it's
quite an urgent situation bees are huge
yeah a full third of the food you eat
every day comes from CRS pollinated by
bees we are losing our bees yes we are
primarily due to a significant Predator
the carnivorous bee wolf so we developed
an Innovative way to help the bees oh I
like this this is topical want to see
how we need the bees is he G to use this
l oh is this like our puzzles though oh
thought we were going to do a puzzle a
be
drone that were training to detect and
attack bolves AKA biller wasps the idea
is for the drones to scare the be Wolves
Away not them oh
nice I would love if none of this comes
back into play with anything else yes
it's just what he does oh yeah got to
protect the hive you're done Peter very
okay I'm going to work here just for
this I wish they would just cut to Peter
with the helmet on being like Oh yeah if
those virtual be wolves you just took
out were real you'd have saved the lives
of about 2500 bees damn wow wow that's
more I'd love to help any way I can
imagine if miles was doing it with
you say way more it's all the stuff we
talked about all the stuff we dreamed
could make the world a better place
that's the idea I really appreciate how
in the first game they set up so many
different things that they're paying off
here Harry no way Dr Kurt Conor no way
it's happening it'll be quick thank you
this is awesome this is my friend Peter
Peter Dr Connor we've actually
met I used to work with Dr Octavius you
came to the lab once to consult on
electrotactile
stimuli oh yes kind of does look like
killan r it's a shame about Dr Octavius
his work had so much promise yeah you're
not going to end up down his path
whatsoever not at all nothing's going to
happen to him dizziness aches
pains
anxiety impulsive thoughts nope I've
never been better erections lasting
longer than 4 hours nothing wrong with
that at all nice to see you again
[Music]
yeah your doctor is the lizard dad
believes in Second Chances oh so he's
it's already happened oh got it feel
free to explore come meet me upstairs
when you're ready oh fascinating this
game just hates origin
stories in Auto
Octavius but I'm pretty sure that Norman
hasn't been the Green Goblin yet that's
true that's true we are watching the
long trajectory
of now do you know the hang on hang on
you're a popular guy sorry it's just my
tutoring job you were saying
you know the stuff everyone studies in
middle school with regor mindle and the
pee plants yeah I think so about
genetics and plant hybridization exactly
so Dr Foster up ahead he's won every top
prize in the field for his work with
plant
genetics it's like the nicest office
I've ever seen for a
startup seems so anti-corporate it's so
so
environmental you look at it that way
got it but that's part of what Harry and
also Norman's wife she was very very
environmental so actually fits so now
where last stop might be my favorite
Peter's office commanding but not
overbearing playful but not tasteless
impressive but not show offy your office
or is it our office our office the
things you've seen today are just a
small taste of what we're working on but
don't decide just yet not until you've
seen this last thing damn you're a
really good guy where's your badge
they're really setting up for what har
is going to do bad so well cuz I'm like
he's the nicest
guy it's going to be all the more
hurtful for Pete when it
happens but yeah they've set up har so I
forgot I didn't remember till right now
like oh yeah he's supposed to go down
some dark
paths
wow was like damn I might sell the house
and just move
here
a
man
Harry this is all so amazing it's
perfect really it's
just things are really hectic right
now what
man when I was in
treatment all I could think about was
what would I do if I
survived start hearing my mom's voice
telling me that our planet is in
trouble and it's my responsibility to
save
it you could just help people in New
York or you could help the
[Music]
world if you join me
there's so much more quit being
Spider-Man and take care of the
environment Pete let miles handle it you
both know you're the smarter
one come
on let's make my mom and may proud
huh it's amazing
Spider-Man but there's one
thing is he going to tell him can I move
my desk over there I like to face the
wall when I
[Laughter]
work Bros for
life oh one quick
thing
yeah that cost them $30,000 to put
together worth it worth it
yeah I'm I'm going to need a little time
to transition out of my tutoring job
of course take whatever time you
need it's all about balance right the
balance but Coney Island later yeah you
bet holy have they still not gone
to Coney
[Music]
Island are we still in the same
day Oh you mean the same day from when
they went to the school
yeah what is the passage your time
yeah thing on the on the water yeah that
I don't know so Sam man the next day
Harry right okay there's no sign of Our
Mysterious Safari Pirates this is going
to be just the struggle to find balance
I love what may said about that balance
is a process not a destination we'll
find him and having to balance the light
in the dark littering come on man
littering oh there's the cloaking
Tech
hexagons Mesto confirmed okay
finally wa what in
the wow another robot maybe I can test
something
out okay go for a ride let's see maybe G
is going to take control sor birdie this
is just as awkward for me as it is for
you there should be a
yep oh is that your
[Music]
home come on birdie let go come on I can
not buy a ticket for this
[Music]
ride
damn I
well he's used to this
part keep forgetting he's got those web
Wings MJ maybe she can dig up some
building records where are we going
now God the speed you generate with
those
things that is true you you do get a
good placees fast yeah it's an old Food
Market owner died last year building
sold a few weeks ago wait this buyer is
it Wilson fist there's some shell
company that's been acquiring property
all over the city like whole city blocks
I tried to do a story on them last month
but it trailed right up every person I
was talking to just vanished go make
yourselves useful our departure is
imminent who are these people no I mean
I think it's the
buyer yeah yeah I just figured usually
someone who buys stuff it's usually him
but yeah you're right rven what are you
looking
for
wait Felicia I get bringing Scorpion and
Lee on a hunt is that in the Black Cat's
a
thief oh hello I
don't damn cra's got so much Tech never
going to win Best in Show with that
attitude
nice doggy kitty
robot said
r c I wonder if miles is in school right
now and that's why he's not able to help
him or maybe he's doesn't feel it's
necessary and needs his help right
now we should just save miles for like
extremely dire situations scorpion
Martin Lee Black
Cat this Craven guy is putting together
quite the team I don't know he's putting
together a team or he's hunting
them I really wonder what the marriage
of the two stories is going to
ultimately feel
[Music]
like
oh oh he got himself a
sandman
scorpion oh damn he really nailed one
into him have a nice
trip
oh dude you're going to need to talk to
JJ and Jameson about a new
one is this
the best you can
do guess he's got no trauma in his
past they said you were a killer oh my
God are they going to kill a scorpion my
disappoint no way I guess they are oh
wow
I didn't expect that dude it didn't even
affect him when he stung him
too like Zero Effect he must have a
really good
diet he's not teaming up with super
villains for some hunt he's hunting
there is prey it's like what rich said
out like you know poor people to hunt
them my future dream
miles why are you wasting your time
doing important schoolwork I wonder if
that picture of uh Rick him and Finn are
still on his desk over
there kind of say how do you just
concentrate on school when
you're where Spider-Man duties and all
that other stuffo
For What in the boyfriend it's almost
here and you're surfing the
web my no one says surfing the web
anymore can you just please get dressed
okay okay see you got your good lipstick
on you must really like this guy huh
wonder if it's just going to be a random
guy
probably
miles see this is what we talked
about next time I promise smile I love
you Spider-Man what do you expect I get
it
but um you might want to oh
yeah oh this is going to be painful for
her
too uhoh he knows she knows the thing is
like do you know what the citizen app is
citizen app tells you about like crimes
happening in your neighborhood and stuff
oh like you can have that and I I see
the alerts all the time I don't do
anything because what am I going to do
but when you're Spider-Man it's like
since going off all the time
yeah now let's see what's up with
Felicia oh wow oh the syum
sorum dror
strange no oh my god really are we doing
this I didn't think we were getting him
in this game oh my God black cat I did
not think we is it setting this is going
to maybe it's the set up just for part
three that'd be amazing little spider
wants to play
huh oh wow yo she
got MJ she stole the wand and Magic
is hey cat can we talk will you slow
down off before I portal you into the
Pacific Ocean how'd you get on our
you're still using the old Channel don't
you have better things to do kid Felicia
you have to stop this is re
who yo that's wild that is so
cool I did not think we were going to
get to do this in the game God what a
surprise try help you your or any other
spider I'm so glad I didn't read any get
spoiled at all it to Ste I had no clue I
can hear you
clowns
wow damn
people watch out the hunters are back a
they must really like me there is so
much happening in
here you got craving you got a colle you
got sling Rings holy oh my God
we're in the Arctic bring my scarf
this is
insane that one can take us right to
Craven this was never about
Craven wait
oh she's got a really good handle how to
use that already feel like she just
jacked
it Felicia does her
research
it's probably got manual this guy you're
Spider-Man you've saved the city before
you'll do it again Spider-Man was right
about you you only care about
yourself look kid not that it's your
business my girlfriend's in
Paris mhm and I got her into trouble
with some bad
people have you ever done something for
love who's your
girlfriend she needs me
now if only I could figure out how to go
more than 10 ft with this thing you went
to the Arctic trust you that's a smart
one just went to the
Artic oh yeah yeah it's true but I don't
think she that was under control that
was just
random here Focus think Eiffel
Tower
yeah you shouldn't trust black catch he
lies so much
though
whoa wow what a dream to have something
like
that okay maybe she was telling the
truth Ora Felicia
Ora thank
you she is so
ugly
so you going to return that to the Sy if
I were if I were Felicia I would have
brought like extra change of clothes
show me Lee or she fits in perfectly
into oh wow do you hear what you just
said yeah it says show me
Lee oh Doctor Strange take
that or Wong oh
I the doctor and I owe you one damn that
was such a great oh man they they got to
appear in the next one I hope
so are we seeing who I think we're going
to see
Mysterio
Mysteria Quinn oh it said Quinn Beck
hello but he's actually a magician
Illusionist and this is doesn't look
like Jake Gyllenhaal and Cole my
technical adviser and
this is the next
generation of entertainment this game is
so much bigger and more expansive than I
was expecting it to no way dude yeah we
haven't even gotten into SYM I know
I know excellent we like haven't even
scratched A Brave Young Man ready to
experience the future
firsthand is there anyone else out there
with courage in their hearts he's
feeling like a David Copperfield and
experience the
future
kind of looks like the eye of aoto there
I was thinking that too there's a kiosk
up ahead just keep
moving if you enjoy your experience
please tell your friends and feel free
to visit one of the many mysterium now
open around the city our free trial ends
soon thank you Betsy I'm sure he
will don't believe anything you see in
there
miles
he deals with real magic and then goes
to the fake magic right after right as
you look at these images I want you to
think about your
future your hopes and curious about what
the point of him being here is ah yes
I'm getting good data oh is this like
Riddler and Batman Forever was
extracting yeah he's extracting he's
stealing from the no
way enjoy the
show don't worry I'll be watching and
listening if at any time you begin to
feel uncomfortable just let oh was he
going
[Music]
[Applause]
DJ kind of looks like K's people in
Quantum
[Music]
Mania oh no
wee this isn't real
man miles is really far from home
now nicely done there you should see an
exit make your way to oh it's like the
trippy nightmare scene that Peter
has are you okay yeah I am very sorry we
will do our best to find what happened
but until
then closed did they see what he saw
miles very jarring in that
yeah uh the future of entertainment
still has some bugs to work out meta hi
Pete cool shirt cool shoes really cool
shoes cool everything really love he's
trying to fit in that's so cool thank
you guys this is my best friend Harry he
just got back from overseas the only one
who doesn't know the truth about them
you mean we're starting up a new
Research
Foundation hey good to meet you new job
huh still going to have time for
tutoring we'll figure it out shall
we actually that thing back there really
messed my head up can we
dip okay
nice meeting you Harry every time I
think we're going to get more of miles
and Peter together they divide them
separate
them you you good yeah actually uh I'll
catch up with you later I'm I mean we
saw a little bit of him Mr negative I
can only imagine it was way more than
what we saw well they seem nice not too
bad they're going to miss out on the
best night of our Lives huh tonight is
the greatest kids album of our childhood
and the top three singles each of our
favorite
attractions really went all out with all
the mini games you can play in this yeah
no idea who you're up against basketball
be drone shooting you'll me it Pete you
got this all right players fingers on
the trigger eyes on the target I love
seeing the three of them together cuz
there was a cool story MJ was talking
about in the first game about the three
of them together and getting pizza and
all that so ni seen the three of them
together and our returning Champion
keeps his crown hold up you guys want
your prize oh we're good thanks that
look good in the CR oh wow you can
literally play any of the games can you
go on the and go on the
rides how did I let you wow oh my God
you can go on roller coasters smell the
popcorn this is why the game took so
long to
develop all this really AIDS in building
up the chemistry with Harry you know
really capturing the tragedy the
impending doom well it's the same thing
with Otto in the first game you know
it's like you're like like I hope it
doesn't happen but even though I know
it's probably going to
happen wow you get to do race cars Birds
that's awesome to explore that's
great oh damn that's a real Ser tomstone
tomstone oh wow because he built Le cars
now he's working on race cars that's F
that's quite the uh change is he
reformed
Tombstone what is he doing
here looks like okay I know we promised
no real life talk but I need oneing the
day MJ you have to come by EMS thanks
for pulling me out man out new office
could have been really bad I know I have
to I've
so he on Craven's list though he's on
the list but he's Pro i' I'm under the
impression he's a good guy now whether
he's good or not he's on that list so
he's going to come for him
Mysterio this park really is a magnet
for reformed super
villains
yeah come on we still have a little more
memory I forget some of the lineage of
things sometimes so Mysterio is reformed
all
right so he already was
okay oh wow going on roller coaster
after
you this is interesting a lot of times
you get into these things you're like
what is the point of this and then you
start fighting slowly unveils it doing
okay I'm really nervous don't worry
about
it it's a good thing you're going on a
roller coaster if you're nervous what
are the chances the person Harry gave
his prize to would be the single Rider
sitting next to him could be one heck of
a meat cute should we tell her tell her
what what are you two whispering about
up there just reminding MJ to keep her
hands inside the vehicle at all times
Final Destination three let's
go
God it's so
real thought Peter's having a really fun
time I'm very happy that they're here
having fun but think of all the crimes
that are happening now cuz he's being
selfish at
but nothing like feeling nervous on a
roller coaster and then getting off
feeling like you're a superhero what's
next our last Showcase of the night the
muscle up oh you know it baby never did
hit that Bell but the dream always kept
me coming back hey Pete this is the best
night of my life hey harry me
too I want to have my birthday here this
year I didn't think I'd get any more of
those there will be plenty
buddy you think Harry's going to die in
this game I really hope not but we shall
see now here's a strapping young go
Peter doing this welcome going to have
to really hold back to break this thing
he come
[Music]
on Slam the controller
down
nice take it easy Harry don't hurt
yourself the only thing that's going to
hurt is your Parker Pride boys boys
they're both great
it's going to be okay
whoa oh he's already
IM y I think there's our
answer okay
hello um okay so I think that's our
answer it's not Edie
proc I guess this really was the year
Harry that was something
else yeah I have
no idea how I did that okay how about we
do something more chill only reason I
even brought up Eddie Brock is because
there was a uh one of the things that uh
Peter looked up um in the backpack we
saw a card that said Eddie's name on it
when he left the Daily Bugle was that
Easter egg they hinted at what's that
hey I'm going to let you two go ahead
and be cute together I'm going to go see
if I can win a couple more
unicorns
a they are adorable
together you look really
happy it's
funny Harry's getting a second chance
but I feel like I'm getting one
too you two are going to make a hell of
a team
the bule
posted did Jonah put you on the front
page oh you're going to be an editor I
should have brought
champagne you know the voice of MJ is
Right Laura Bailey oh nice Jah posted
the new guy
story MJ there's a new guy it already
has 5,000 views any Brook I don't
know I've got to write a different kind
of
story when his trust
somehow hey you'll come up with
something you always
do thanks
sure yeah what are they celebrating hey
if you need some help from your friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man I'd say we make
a hell of a team too even if I do forget
the champag
next
time really do compliment each other
very well it's not a damsel and distress
thing I mean I would love to be
Spider-Man and help out with my
girlfriend's stories he went this way oh
out of the way you're attacking at the
carnival
oh Tombstone see
yeah eyes on
tombstone he doesn't want to
fight
Tombstone uh
boy
whoa that's awesome when you're in the
right place at the right
time thrw the spider away
now I got you Lonnie
oh no is that what MJ's on don't fall oh
no I'm sorry Lonnie I really do want to
help
you oh man New York has been just
getting
[Music]
destroyed
it's going to be
okay whoa
who that going to save a roller coaster
damn awesome don't worry I've got
you that went in sync with the loop wow
spider
ride
hang
on it is Final Destination 3 but with
Spider-Man
Jesus oh my miles where are
you the single
Rider but Harry has that surprising
strength too oh
yeah balance balance
it remember balance is a process okay
last stop everyone
out
oh
no
NJ we got to get away she stunned one of
us I think they they were
taking is this where Venom shows
up no Venom will comes up way
later I think Venom's like tilt like
towards the end
of
oh damn what did you do here it's like
Spider-Man
one damn she been on this one roller
coaster this entire time wants to
conquer her
fears I'm
sorry Harry oh
h
Pete
what no hang
on I did not think that was going to
happen they both just put it together
beete I love the unexpected build with
the storytelling like you're lot of like
wonder what the point of being here is
and then boom something has
happens the developments they they sneak
up on you wonder if Harry's going to be
upset that he never told
him hang
[Music]
on oh still The Fallout of devil's
breath talk we sure
do Spider-Man I know I know
but first what are those things coming
out of
you I think it's my
treatment yikes feels malevolent
man Dr Connor said it's some kind of
self-learning Exo Suit but I had no idea
it
could
wait you know what this means right team
up for a while Powers Yeah just think
about all the stuff we could do to he
the world uh he's not wanting
that sorry does it want to be part of
Peter guess I still got to figure out
how this thing
works well cuz it always wants to bond
with a host it's a real shame neither of
us has a state-of-the-art science lab to
run some
tests I'll go make sure the coast is
clear meet you
there me call when you're
[Music]
ready oh this is really interesting Dam
is it technically possibly could be Edie
Brock at the end of the we'll see he
watch
this
whoa you okay come on let's see what
else this thinging
do good thing there's no security
cameras in this place what are you doing
science buddy I'm doing science science
science Bros for life so
Spider-Man you told MJ but not your best
friend to protect you I I wanted
to right yeah I get
it and that kid you're tutoring he's the
other one A lot happened while you were
in that
tank trust me I
know feel some anger in him coming up
yeah whoops
uh scream that out of you I'm going to
make some coffee it looks like it's
going to be a long night although
surprisingly he's been pretty positive
for most of the game thus far but I like
how they're introducing the Sim the
Symbio like or whatever they're kind of
call it this time around as like there's
like a sense of wonder to it and not
just something threatening right away
you
[Music]
know